[音楽]
[拍手]
こんにちは工学部政治学科1年生の三宅
壮大です今回私はプレゼンテーションを
有志場所becauseというタイトルで
行っていきたいと思います主に課外活動と
私の実課題活動によって私の人生がどんな
ふうに変わったのかどんな風になんで私は
今でも課外活動を続けているのかという
ことについて話していきたいと思います
ですがちょっと本題に自己紹介に入る前に
一つだけリラックスしてほしいなという
ふうに思いますこのスピーチを考えている
時に実は5回ぐらいやってました何話し
たらいいんだろうなってめちゃ緊張して今
もめっちゃ手が触れてるんですけども
そういう風にぐちゃぐちゃになって考えた
結果
かっこつけるのをやめましたなので今回
もう多分私の変顔もちょっと出てくるかも
しれないんですけどリラックスしてどう
いうことがこの人言いたいんだろうって
思いながら聞いてくれたら嬉しいなという
ふうに思いますはいじゃあ自己紹介です
最初私は中等部で慶應に入学しましたで
中等部の時は
ESS英語研究会とソフトボール部に所属
してそこに力を入れまし
た思考に入学して
クロス部と生徒会に所属してそこにも力を
入れて
頑張ってみましたが高校1年生の時に
コロナになって学校がなくなりました
その時に何かしなきゃいけないなっていう
衝動に駆られて
課外活動をやってみようかなという風に
考え始めました
2つ自分の中で思い出に残っている
プログラムがあります
1つ目は高校2年生の春の時に参加した
女優プログラムというプログラムですこれ
はアメリカにある
ジャパンソサエティという企業がやって
いるプログラムなんですけれども世界で
活躍するリーダーの方々からお話を聞いて
リーダーシップとは何かについて学ぶ
2つ目が
集大成として
臨んだチャレンジしたプログラムなんです
けれどもスタンバイエンジニアに
参加しましたこれはスタンフォード大学に
よって開かれているプログラムで
約半年間オンラインでスタンフォード大学
だったりとかスタンフォード大学のお
知り合いの方からのゲストレクチャーを
聞きますこれによって日米関係の変遷だっ
たりとか発令関係の歴史だったりとかを
学んでたくさんの
友達に出会いました今回はこの
散歩でいたプログラムについて重きを置い
て話していきたいと思いますその他校内
プログラム作成って書いてあるんですけど
さっきの出てたように今からの売ってたの
で覚えてくれてる人がいたら嬉しくなって
いうふうに思います
今やってるかというと
慶応大学で法学部政治学科に入っていて
慶応ディベートスクワットというところで
英語の即興のイベントをしていますあとは
インターンをやらせていただいたりして
毎日充実した日々を過ごしていると思い
ます
はいでは問題に入ってきます
2つ話すことがあると言ったと思うんです
けど1つ目は中日fromyour
課外活動を始めるときとか何か新しいこと
を実際に始める時ってどうしよう」って
最初
1歩の皆さんが大変だと思いますその時に
私がどうして
immという風に感じられているかどうし
てそういうふうに言い聞かせているの
かっていう話を2つ話したいです
いろんな人が言ってると思うんですけれど
も
課外活動に行くと大学受験しなくていい
じゃん
羨ましいという風にめちゃめちゃいろんな
ことに言われましたこれ正直私ちょっと
ムカついちゃうんですけど
内部進学でも大変だよっていう風に返した
いってたまに思いますでもムカつくのって
多分上司だからで私たちは共通テストでも
いいし私たちは大学受験の勉強を前にし
なくていいっていう特権があると思ってい
ます
そういう時に受験生が勉強している間
私たちは何ができると思いますか
少し学校の外のことに目を向けてみるのは
どうでしょうか
自分のコンプレッションから抜け出して
新しいことに挑戦してみることってすごく
時間と体力とあとやる気が必要だと思い
ますそれをできるのは
京王線だと私は勝手に思っています
これは私が散歩でJAPANに参加してい
た時の写真なんですけれどもこんなふうに
パソコン1台だけで世界でつなげられ
るってすごくワクワクしませんかパソコン
じゃなくてもいいと思います1回私がやっ
たことがあるのは
ジモティーでボランティア」って調べて
地元の本当に自分の最寄り駅のゴミ拾い
活動参加したことがありますそこで何か
色んな主婦の一つであったり
そういう新たな
経験がありました
少し
勇気を出してみれば
少し自分に自信を持てれば
課外活動って簡単に参加できるものだと
いうふうに思っております
安佐県のリズム利用
しましょう
[音楽]
人っていろんな要素でできていると思い
ます例えば私は英語が得意だな自分で得意
だと思うようにしてて自分はクロスをやっ
ている経験
がいろんなプログラムに参加してとかそう
いう経験がたくさんあると思います
でもやっぱり自信がないのは何なのかって
いうと英語ができるって言っても
私より英語できる人ってたくさんいると
思います私18年今まで生きている中
ずっと日本に過ごしてきて私より英語の
単語がもっとあるものとか英語の単語力
だったりとか自分よりも
認定だったりとか帰国支援の人って私より
も話せる人たくさんいると思いますそう
いう風に考えると1つのところを見ると
自分自身がなくなっちゃうってめっちゃ
不安に思います
でも私は課外活動に参加していて思った
ことがあります
一つのキースをいろんな人でシェアして
いるのはしょうがないです英語が得意って
いうのは思ってる人多分世界中に何万人と
います
例えば言う経験も私よりも上手い人も
たくさんこの中にいると思うしいろんな人
とシェアしてるからこそ自分にユニークな
ものではない
でもこの一つ一つのピースを全部
持ち合わせてるのって自分だけだという風
に思っていますそれが皆さんの個性だと
いう風に私は考えます
一つ一つは自分にユニークじゃないかも
しれないけど全てを
持ち合わせているのは自分っていう風に
考えたら少しポジティブになれると思い
ませんか
そういう風に考えて相打ちと言い聞かせる
ようになってくれたらすごく嬉しいなと
いうふうに思います
2つ目に話したいことは
課外活動に参加することによってなんで
もっと自分がスペシャルな存在になるのか
について話します
1つ目Nobemy
becauss
正直言って多分課外活動に参加したいとか
こういうアカデミック系のに参加したとき
忘れちゃう情報ってめちゃめちゃあると
思います自分何を学んだかと言われてすぐ
に覚えやすくてやっぱり難しいです
情報を忘れてしまうけど人の顔とか人と
話したことだったりとかその人その友達
ってあんまり忘れづらいと思います
私はINJAPANに飯田パンツ
サンフォードインジャパンプログラムに
参加してたくさんの特別な友達ができまし
た
深夜の2時ぐらいまで
ズームして恋話したりとかそういう小さな
経験すごく楽しいと私は感じていて学校外
の外に出ることで新しい友達と出会え
出会えるのが
課外活動のすごくユニークな伝説はという
風に考えます
2つめ利用しましょう
[音楽]
これ私がすごくずっと思っていることなん
ですけれども
学校の中に生活していると自分の殻みたい
なものができていると思います
よくみんなこれ私のキャラじゃないって
言いますよね
そのキャラを作らなくていいのが課外活動
だという風に考えます
自分の外の自分のコンフォートゾーンの外
に出ることってすごく怖いですだって誰も
知らないでも誰も知らないからこそ新しい
自分になれる新しい私がなりたい自分に
なれるっていう風に思っています
私が時々プレゼンで英語しゃべってると
思うんですけどそれかっこつけたいから
じゃなくて英語を喋ってる自分は
課外活動してる時の自分に近いです
英語系の国際系のプログラムに参加してい
てからなんですけれども
英語をしゃべっている時はもっと自分に
自信を持てるって思うし自分がなりたい
自分に自分がなりたい自分に近づいている
風に近づいているというふうに思うので
英語で少しちょこちょこ話していました
こんなふうに新しく自分を作れる機会が
課題活動だと思っているのでぜひ皆さんに
も自分の
ゾーンから抜け出してほしいなと思ってい
ます今回私2つ話してきたんですけども
2つ1つ目が入室場所っていう話をして
もっと自分に自信を持ってくださいここに
いるだけで皆さんはすごく素敵な存在だと
いうふうに私は思います
2つ目もっとお互い活動に参加したら
もっと自分の殻を上から
抜け出したらあなたはもっと素敵な存在に
なると私は思っています
これ私がこの話をしたことでカラー活動
だったりとか
新しいことに挑戦するモチベーションに
なっていたらいいなという風に思います
いろいろ話してきたんですけどこれも課外
活動って考えたら忘れちゃいますよね
季節だけ覚えて帰ってください
ありがとうございました
[拍手]